it's so cliche to say that you're the
average of the five people that you
spend the most time with but if you do
not want to have this culture around you
find people that also don't want to have
this culture around you if I was a young
guy that was struggling I would
basically put out a call to Arms the
college that I go to at the high school
that I go to and the WhatsApp chats that
I'm in I'm struggling and I want to
improve myself does anyone else want to
come with me find a little group of guys
you will be able to absolutely crush it
together I'm confident that you will you
will help to raise each other up you
will support each other when things go
badly over time all of you will begin to
separate yourself out from the pack and
the bar has never been set lower to be a
better person it's exciting I actually
do feel very hopeful now